I don't like your attitude
looking at guide you say it's a Friday
edition of PFT Ooty also available on
the PFT p.m. podcast and it's Peter King
joining me today because even when we're
not on TV Chris Sims refuses to work
more than four days per week so thank
you Peter for filling in for Chris Sims
it's great to see you it's great to talk
to you that you're there in New York
City actually you're in Brooklyn now I
think but still you're in a spot where a
lot of this covin 19 reality is much
more pressing and much more real than it
is elsewhere in the country so we're
glad to see you're doing well we hope
you're staying safe and we hope that
more and more people are taking the
situation seriously yeah Mike you know
and it is true I'm kind of in the belly
of the beast and most people in New York
I have to go into Manhattan to do a
little bit of volunteer work the other
day I guess I didn't have to and and to
donate blood and it was an absolute
total ghost town that was Wednesday and
they say don't come within six feet of
anybody I didn't come within 16 feet of
anybody and so I think people in New
York most people are taking it seriously
I think we've got to somehow you know
Mike what what would the authorities in
China have done to that kid on the beach
in Florida who said hey Corona if I get
it I don't care this is my time to party
where do you think he would be would he
ever be heard from again
and so though I think somehow someway
we've got to get a handle on the people
who the the sort of corona truthers who
don't care about it because they're
gonna put us all behind the eight-ball
for about five more months than we
probably need to be yeah I mean you're
absolutely right there's that segment of
society typically younger people who
aren't taking it seriously who are still
listening to the grossly outdated
messages that we got early on like
gets a flu and it's the hoax and they're
using that to justify whatever it is
that they choose to do and I think it's
important that everyone used their
platforms and I've been trying to use
mine all week Peter to get people
especially in that age group
wake up grow up and do what needs to be
done and what needs to be done is
nothing we are all very good at doing
nothing just get your ass home sit on
the couch play xbox or ps4 watch movies
don't go anywhere don't do anything
you're finally getting the license to do
what you want to do which is hang out
and do nothing and they don't want to do
that yeah it's because they've been
looking forward to going to Florida for
so long and the last thing we could do
is to disappoint those those poor 20
year olds who want to drink all day and
sit in the Sun anyway yeah I mean look
and I don't want to make it a
generational thing but damn it it is and
I think it's important for those of us
who are old enough and wise enough to
realize that this is a problem that
we're taking it seriously we need to use
our platforms our voices privately and
publicly to get the younger people to
understand they need to take this
seriously and the sooner they do the
sooner we can get through all of this
together all right we're here to provide
you a diversion and a distraction from
the sad realities of normal life which
is anything but normal so we're going to
go through some of the issues that have
bubbled up throughout the week in the
National Football League including
something that just as of yesterday the
Rams had Todd Gurley under contract
we're in discussions about a trade
reportedly the Falcons and the Dolphins
were the most interested the rams cut
Todd Gurley to avoid having another ten
and a half million dollars become fully
guaranteed under his contract that he
signed less than two years ago and now
Peter already he's agreed to terms with
the Atlanta Falcons well I'll just say
this Mike I think one of the weirdest
things in our society is and I heard it
last night I don't know I was a we
watched a little TV but I also did a
little bit of work otherwise and so I
was paying attention
to Twitter and to a couple of talk shows
and I was and all these people were
saying oh my god they it and and I'm it
was like poor todd gurley so I went to
the trusty over the Capcom site
Jason Fitzgerald does a great job of
curating salaries using Mike Florio Adam
Schefter Ian Rapoport whoever else you
know and uses all their information and
curates all the salaries and does a
fantastic job and I wanted to see one
thing career earnings so that you know I
want to find out should I feel sorry for
Todd Gurley Mike Todd Gurley who I
believe is 26 years old has made 38
million dollars so I'm sorry the violins
shall not play in the Peter King
residence for Todd Gurley and I get it
everybody said well geez they're really
you know the salaries are just screwing
over the running backs and and all that
stuff they're not screwing over the
running backs they're paying the running
backs what they are worth in the NFL
today and if Todd Gurley didn't have
Mike whatever he had if he didn't have
the arthritic knee or what you know look
I don't know what Todd Gurley has and if
I were the Falcons I'd be really really
careful quite honestly before you
actually doc you sign a contract or
however they do those things now with
Todd Gurley because I would want how do
you not have it's my thought how do you
not have your own team physician your
own orthopedist how is it possible that
you actually sign them without doing a
very thorough physical exam on Todd
Gurley that's my big question hasn't one
of the biggest issues over the last two
years in the NFL almost two years hasn't
one of the biggest issues been you know
what's wrong with Todd Gurley you know
why have they have the Rams gone from
hardly ever playing them and and playing
them in a limited way
and running him some I mean he went from
being the super star running back at the
NFL to now it's almost like he's David
Johnson and so I I don't know Mike
that's a that's a multi-faceted answer
and I'd love to hear your thoughts yeah
and let's unpack some of this because I
think one of the reasons that this has
been so weird and strange and vague the
Rams have treated the condition of Todd
Gurley zni like it's some sort of a
state secret and I think one of the
reasons why Todd Gurley is extremely
sensitive about any talk regarding his
knee he got mad about it last year when
reporters would bring it up Peter I just
wrote a few stories about it and he
blocked me on Twitter for crying out
loud
I didn't even insult him let me earn the
block Todd let me say something nasty if
you're gonna block me for crying out
loud
I didn't say anything but he's been very
sensitive about it and here's the
reality
you mentioned the career earnings look
he had three years in as the 10th
overall pick in the draft in 2015 the
reigning NFL Offensive Player of the
Year the rams could have played it out
like the Chargers did with Melvin Gordon
finished the fourth year of your rookie
contract play out the option year of
your rookie deal and then become a free
agent
the Rams paid this guy after three
seasons he made thirty four point five
million guaranteed over two years at
17.25 million a year for a running back
no running back makes that other than
Todd Gurley that is unbelievable and
then the way the contract was structured
on the verge of having another ten and a
half million become fully guaranteed the
Rams cut the cord that contract was
negotiated to force the Rams to make a
decision so now Todd Gurley becomes a
free agent which every player wants make
me a free agent every year so I can go
out and get the highest possible payday
he's got thirty four and a half million
that he made over two years he's a free
agent able to sign with any team he has
a deal with the Falcons then next
morning he wins it's a jackpot it's a
brilliant move by him by his agents and
the Rams screwed this up because they
just could have paid out every dollar
under his rookie deal five years said
see you later
god bless Godspeed good luck like Melvin
Gordon is currently trying to do and
finding a new deal that way todd gurley
won big-time because he'd had been a
free agent anyway he'd assigned with the
Falcons anyway and he's got thirty four
and a half million over the last two
years to show for it
do you know the money yet from the
Falcons I don't know it yet and I'll
tell you what here's another thing that
makes the deal great for the the Todd
Gurley and his agent thirty one point
nine five million of the money he's made
the last two years is not subject to
offset of any kind no offset it's only
two point five five million the first
two point five five million he makes
from the Falcons will be subject to
offset language so look I think I don't
know I was spitballing earlier today
Peter I think five six million is fair
for Todd Gurley at this point when you
consider he will have a limited role I
wonder how much he accepts the fact that
he's not a workhorse that it needs to be
a limited role and he needs to be paid
accordingly he's got to get to that
point where he accepts he's not the guy
that he was when he signed that contract
in 2018 yeah I mean when you know when
Tom Brady signed with the with the Bucks
a friend of mine you know another media
guy wrote to me and he said I'll tell
you who the who the buck should go get
right now for very cheap Dion Lewis
because Dion Lewis basically can be that
guy out of the backfield that Tom Brady
is gonna need is his crutch you know the
pass catching back and probably get him
for cheap and that reminds me of the
fact that I don't think you're signing
Todd Gurley to be Derek Henry you
obviously you shouldn't be you're
signing Todd Gurley to be a
complimentary piece and a co running
back with somebody else so I think he'd
be very fortunate Mike to get a 6-minute
to to clear this year six million
dollars or maybe you know if if they
give them some sort of bonus and a lower
salary this year they just need to be
able to in 2021 if things blow up and it
goes bad
they need to let him go and not have say
9 million bucks dead cat money yeah I
agree with you completely and let me
tell you there's another reason why this
physical that will be conducted by
someone somewhere somehow under these
kovat 19 procedures a neutral doctor who
may have never conducted a physical
examination of a professional athlete in
his or her life yeah if there is a
failure of that examination if that knee
keeps Todd Gurley from passing the
physical Peter the next move by Gurley
on this broader chessboard is to go back
to the Rams and say hey that ten and a
half million that would have become
fully guaranteed if I was on the roster
today it was injury guaranteed I can't
pass a physical right you owe me another
ten and a half million on top of the
thirty four and a half million and that
may work out to forty five million
all told for Todd Gurley for two years
of football if he can't pass a physical
and if he can't play and you know if
you're Todd Gurley there's an argument
to be made that maybe you just walk away
with your forty five million plus what
you made your first three years in the
NFL and call it a career so there's two
things at play here Mike the more I
think about Todd Gurley suppose the Todd
Gurley is living in LA okay to me the
best thing that he could do if he's
living in LA is he goes and sees dr.
Neil L at rush you know who did Tom
Brady's knee surgery in 2008 he did
shoot who's the receiver with the Rams
who's whose knee Super Cup a year ago
yeah cool yeah that's right that's right
Cooper Cup he did his surgery and he's
obviously very well trusted by NFL teams
if he's in LA that's who should examine
his knee that's number one number two he
went to Georgia if I'm not mistaken he
lives in Georgia as a home in Georgia or
something and so would not he be
eligible perhaps to get one of the
Falcons team orthopedist not in the
facility but somewhere in Atlanta too
do the exam of his knee that I I mean
that is a little bit shaky what if the
guy what if what if todd gurley has an
apartment in atlanta i wouldn't he then
couldn't the neutral doctor be somebody
who the falcons at least if he doesn't
work for the Falcons that he would be
very familiar with i think you're
absolutely right now the way they wrote
up the rules on monday it can't be a
physical performed at the team facility
and the team doctors can't go to the
player it has to be a neutral local
physician but you're right in that
community in atlanta the falcons doctors
will know someone that they trust to do
that physical and they can guide them on
what they need to look at and what they
need to do and if there's an MRI or an
x-ray or whatever the falcons doctors
can also take a look at that before
anything gets finalized but that ten and
a half million that the Rams would Oh
Todd Gurley that his injury guaranteed
at the time he was terminated you can't
cut a guy if he's not healthy enough to
pass a physical so if he fails the
physical the argument becomes and my
guess is it would be resolved in a
grievance procedure that the Rams Oh
Todd Gurley another ten and a half
million dollars on top of what they've
already paid him so look this was a win
for Todd Gurley Shannon sharp and I got
into a back-and-forth last night on
Twitter that hey what happened to you
know he signed a contract and honor the
contract the bottom line is the contract
was constructed to front-load a ton of
money and put triggers in there to force
the Rams to make early decisions Gurley
got free agency and thirty four and a
half million dollars for two years he
won big time and the Rams lost big time
Peter and you look at the Rams now my
god what have they done with some of the
contracts they've negotiated in recent
years Jared Goff got a check for 21
million yesterday he has a cap number of
36 million they're looking to trade
Brandon cooks who they gave a contract
to sight unseen when they gave up a
first-round pick two years ago these
chickens have come home to roost in a
big way for the Rams and this team is
going to be very different than the team
that went to the Super Bowl less than
two years ago here's the thing what's
amazing about Brandon cooks
I mean just think about this just
imagine if he gets traded you know and
I've heard a lot of things you know
maybe Tampa I mean I look Tampa's
already got an embarrassment of riches
at the receiver position but but
wherever okay just imagine think of this
Mike you're 26 years old you played for
the Saints the Patriots the Rams
already imagine if you end up on a
fourth team by the time you're age 26
and a fourth team in the last five years
and it's really his career has really
been amazing think about it and again I
you know I don't know what's gonna
happen to him but you know he's played
for he's played for Sean Payton and
gotten passes from Drew Brees played for
Bill Belichick caught passes from Tom
Brady played for Sean McVeigh caught
passes from Jared golf I mean obviously
he's not the same league with those guys
but he has played for three Premier
franchises and and imagine if he goes to
another team that makes the playoffs
this year it's just you talk about
that's gonna be one of the strangest
careers in recent NFL history
if he gets traded particularly if he
gets traded to a good team and it's
amazing because he was a first-round
pick of the Saints in 2013 the Saints
got a first-round pick when they traded
him to the Patriots who got a
first-round pick when they traded him to
the Rams I don't know what the Rams are
looking for for Brandon cooks but that
would be the equivalent of drawn for
aces if you hit four first-round picks
they've been invested at his guy at one
time or another well here's the one
thing that the Rams could do if you
think about it Mike if I were the Rams I
wouldn't really be that concerned about
compensation obviously you 1a1 you're
probably not gonna get a one in part
because the same thing that that that a
lot of teams thought when they were
thinking about DeAndre Hopkins guy wants
a new contract guys gonna be gonna cost
a very high pick to us we can get a
receiver in the second round this year
maybe even in the third round
who would make a third over it over the
life of his contract that DeAndre
Hopkins would make when he walked in the
door with a new contract so let's let's
just do that
so think about it this way Mike if I'm
the Rams and I get offered and I don't
even know who it was and I get offered
the thirty eighth or forty fourth pick
in the draft for Brandon cooks I take it
because then you have salary management
over the next four years with a bright
prospect player who in another year
could have been the 16th pick in the
draft
you know what the combine this year Mike
you heard it the exact same way I heard
it that this is possibly and probably
the greatest year ever for wide
receivers in the 85-year history of the
NFL Draft and if that be the case Mike
if DK Metcalf went 64th last year and
Terry McLaren went 76th last year
I mean imagine what you could get at 80
you know theoretically you could get a
year one starter and that you could rely
on you could get a a michael Gallup Plus
and so I kind of look at this if I'm the
Rams I'm not that obsessed with what I'm
gonna get in return
if mentally I'm thinking to myself I
would rather have right now the 50th
pick in the draft right now then I would
have then I then have Brandon cooks
because I get salary relief and I get a
younger player and I get a player who
maybe he's not gonna be as good as cooks
but in this offense you can hide a lot
of deficiencies he's got an eight
million dollar salary of four million
dollar roster bonus this year next year
twelve million dollar salary thirteen
fourteen after that he's signed for four
more years he's got that concussion
issue as well that may cause some teams
to think twice about trading for Brandon
cooks and look I don't think they're
gonna cut him if they can't trade him
but I think given this roster transition
that the Rams are currently finding
themselves in it
consideration as they reshape the team
they got to get a running back though
Peter look
I don't think Jared Goff is the same
quarterback without a weapon like Todd
Gurley to open up the offense Jared Goff
doesn't have the mobility to extend
plays you give him a clean pocket he's
going to be fine but you take away Todd
Gurley I mean look last year they didn't
make the playoffs because Todd Gurley
wasn't as effective as he'd been in the
past this could be a quick turnaround
from a team that looked like it was on
the front end of a dynasty to a team
that's going to be scratching and
clawing to be competitive in the best
division in football well yeah and now
because what you think about now
compared to two years ago it looked like
the Arizona Cardinals were gonna be on a
five-year bender you know really even
after they announced Kliff Kingsbury
didn't we all think oh my god Kliff
Kingsbury had a losing record you know
in college got fired in the middle of
his last year in college and you're
hiring him to help rebuild our franchise
well a year later that looks different a
year later Kyler Murray looks pretty
good and a year later DeAndre Hopkins
looks really good so you know the
Cardinals are not gonna be a gimmie for
anybody in that division that's number
one and number two you know Mike I will
never forget last year in May I wrote a
column and I ranked the team's 1 to 32
and I have the San Francisco 49ers 7th
and so of all the times in my life where
I've written idiotic things that people
said that I was a nincompoop
with life and dollar signs before that
I'm serious that was a time where I
could not believe that that I I couldn't
believe some of the things are being
thrown my way
all's fair in love and and collum nicing
but I'll never forget that and I after I
finished that I was on a talk show in
San Francisco and they said are you sure
and I said hey look I'm gonna pick two
or three teams every year a little
higher than people would think but all
I'm saying about the San Francisco 49ers
is that they're going to have a guy
he was a top 10 or 12 quarterback
they're gonna have the best offensive
line in football I think and and that
was even and I don't even know what Bosa
is yet but you throw those two things
into the equation when you play a lot of
close games anyway and they're gonna be
good now how did we know that even
though Kittel it out a good 18 he had a
transcendent 19 obviously but all I'm
saying is that every year there's one of
those teams that skyrockets last year
was the 49ers so and then obviously the
Seahawks John Schneider could be my
executive of the year at any year and
they're gonna wait out the storm I still
think it's 50/50 that they get they get
Jadeveon Clowney back you know for less
money than he would want to but by the
time football starts whenever that is
he'll get over his bitterness and you
know if the Seahawks have them he'll be
a huge piece with Bruce Irvin you know
trying to you know do a reclamation
project on his career so all I'm saying
is that you're right about the Rams the
Rams two years ago the end of the
Superbowl two years ago you think man
these guys are gonna be good for a long
time hey it's there's no guarantees in
today's football yeah you're absolutely
right and one of the things there's no
guarantee about is that football is even
going to start on time given what's
currently happening in the world free
agency was effective but not as much as
I thought it would be the draft clearly
affected it's not going to happen in Las
Vegas it'll happen in a TV studio
somewhere and I think I don't have the
biggest ratings it will ever have had
because it's the only oasis of actual or
semi actual sports over the next couple
of months but Peter I think the
offseason programs won't happen the
question is will training camp open on
time and what impact will that have on
the season it well the season even
happen on time a lot of open questions
and I hope the NFL is planning for all
possible scenarios Mike let's take them
one at a time you know let's forget
about the off season program I can't see
it happening or maybe it happens in a
very very abbreviated way say for the
first
weeks of June I don't know but I can't
see any group team activities at the
absolute earliest before June 1st
but again that's me just spitballing
being obsessed with this thing over the
last couple of weeks so then you start
to think about okay training camp will
that happen I mean probably now training
camp happens without fans do you play
the preseason games as normal and are
you even going to have I mean after
watching you know the Spring Breakers
and after watching some other elements
of our society there's a huge wedding
the other night in a Brooklyn community
that had like 500 people and the police
had to break it up and so there's
obviously people are still getting used
to the fact that you can't do group
things anymore and how much of a factor
and how long it lasts Mike ID I don't
think there's any guarantee at all that
this season starts on time I I just
don't I and I'm not trying to be an
alarmist I'm just trying to say you know
we'll see and I think there you can't
make any solid predictions about the
timing of things to happen in the future
in this country and if you somebody
would listen to that and say oh you're
crazy the football season is six months
away look what happened in China they
get they got rid of it they aren't even
having anymore coronavirus cases Mike
they dragged infected family members
away from each other and you know they
kept them for 14 days without any
contact with their families do we have
the will in this country to do that I
don't think so and so that's why okay in
three months it disappeared in in China
three months and I don't even know
disappeared is probably the wrong word
but in three months they basically got a
great handle on it in China do you
seriously think in three months we'll
have a great handle on this with what
you've seen on the news in the last few
days
I don't yeah and I have
problem with you being an alarmist Peter
if there had been more alarmist several
months ago we wouldn't be in this mess
right now where we're preparing for
hospitals throughout the areas where the
greatest concentration of infected
individuals are residing are going to be
overcome by the the ill and not be able
to properly care for everyone because
there were no alarmists there were no
people who were seeing and understanding
and connecting the dots between what was
happening in China and what was
inevitably going to happen here and look
I've been thinking about all the things
that could unfold Peter I don't know
where the testing technology is going to
be in September but I could see a
scenario where the NFL goes forward in
empty stadiums with every player tested
before every game and if you're positive
you're yanked from the pool of players
and you're put somewhere until you're
free from the virus if you're negative
you get to play in the game
and I can see the NFL moving heaven and
earth to try to make that happen and
again I don't know where the testing
technology is going to be in September
but if we can get to the point where
testing is automatic and easy and
available I could see that being the
scenario where the NFL sacrifices the
revenue that would come through the
ticket office but still makes the TV
money by putting the games on TV which
would be wildly successful and have the
highest ratings ever if we're still in
this weird existence where we're staying
indoors all the time the one thing that
I was just thinking about it echoes most
of what you said but just think now
about if you had a debate between the
two presidential candidates on
television on a Wednesday night in
September and let's say a Tuesday night
in October before they let's say there's
two debates well I think we've all
assumed under normal conditions that
because TV ratings were down 8% NFL TV
ratings were down 8% in 2016 because
everybody went crazy over the
presidential election into South 2016
we've all assumed that 2020 would be the
same but now you are absolutely right
even with the gigantic ratings that a
couple of debates would engender and all
of the talk would engender about the
presidential election which I still
think would happen regardless of you
know the the state of this disease
if it happens Mike if it happens in that
way I still think the NFL will get
absurd ratings and get higher ratings
than they had last year because all
those people who said yeah I'm gonna go
take a long bike ride on Sunday or I'm
gonna go do this on Sunday or I'm going
to the mall or I'm gonna go you know go
to the beach you know with my friends I
mean if you're in California I mean
that's just I I mean again we can't see
the future but the future looks pretty
cloudy to me and on a cloudy rainy day
what do people do they stay in and watch
TV and if the games are played in the
NFL I think they would stay in and watch
that and you know that also has to be
considered within the context of the
possibility that there are no games and
the season is a wipeout and I'm in the
process of trying to get to the bottom
of this I've asked the league I've asked
the Union they haven't gotten back to me
which tells me I may be on to something
here what does the CBA say about the
possibility of the NFL not playing its
games this year do the players still get
paid and if they are required to be paid
even if the NFL doesn't play games what
does that do to some of the teams not
all of them but some of them do you have
the liquidity to pay these guys if
you're not getting your money do the
network's still have to pay well might
for games that aren't played I mean
there's a lot of layers and levels to
that as well member back in 2011 when
the lockout was looming there were
reports that the network still had to
pay the league even if the games didn't
get played is that part of it as well
that there's a rabbit hole here that
could get very dark and very precarious
for the NFL if they don't play games
this season Mike let's let's talk about
one franchise in particular let's talk
about the New York Giants
okay so the New York Giants this is the
11th year of MetLife Stadium and when
they started the the stadium they
offered two levels of people able to buy
sweets okay
you could either buy them on a 10-year
contract or you could buy it on a 5-year
contract so in any case you know all of
their sweet I I shouldn't say all first
for all I know maybe they've got some
people who go year to year I don't know
but but the majority of their sweet
holders are up right now okay so that is
revenue that John Mayer this is a family
business
okay so John Mayer and Steve Tisch they
rely on that revenue to run this
franchise okay
and I'm not saying anybody should be
holding a canned goods drive for the New
York Giants the only point I'm making is
that in a normal year the New York
Giants right now would have money coming
in you saw this week that the Giants
basically deferred their season ticket
payments for the year until some months
down the road now okay so you've got
that and you've got the fact that I'm
sure that people who have to pay and
whatever the number is a hundred
thousand dollars to renew their suite
for this year I mean somebody have a
have the ability right now to write a
check for a hundred grand in this
environment in this climate after the
last two weeks again I'm sure a lot of
people do but will people actually do
that and the one last thing I would say
what franchise in the NFL has the worst
record in the league over the last three
years the New York Giants are in a bad
place for this whole thing to be
happening right now yeah that's a great
point and there are other teams that are
owned by families and that's all they do
or primarily what they do like the
Steelers for example you don't have
other money that's going to get you
through this or that can fund a year of
pain
player salaries basically loan yourself
money from other operations you're gonna
have to go out and get a loan and hey
the good news is the interest rates
gonna be fairly low but the bad news is
that money that gets lost when a
football season goes away never comes
back and I guess the irony and I never
know when to use that word properly but
a week after we stop talking about a
potential lockout in 2021 there may be
an involuntary lockout in 2020 and a lot
of issues that would arise if and when
it happens and those would all be
immaterial to the bigger problem because
if they can't play football in September
Peter that means this thing ended up
being much more of a mess than we
thought it was going in yeah and and
Mike I mean I you and I are sitting here
a week ago basically trying to figure
out are the players gonna vote for this
or the players not gonna vote for it and
just think how close it was think of
this on the average NFL team 33 players
voted for 30 voted against that's how
close this was all I'm saying is let's
just say it had been reversed how many
players would be holding their heads in
their hands right now saying oh my god
what have we done not the fabulously
wealthy ones but most of the other ones
and imagine the 11 thousand players who
are getting their pensions with this new
contract are getting their pensions
raised by 53% you know from thirty to
forty six thousand dollars in the first
year I mean you think those people might
need that money right now so I guess the
point I'm making overall is I think it's
probably a pretty good idea they passed
that CBA even though there's still a
rock-solid contingent of players who
hate it and you got to wonder how many
owners after the fact or wishing they
had voted it down so they could yank
that offer off the table and wait a year
year and a half to assess all the damage
to their broader portfolio and then
figure out how to make as much money as
they can back from the players in the
next CBA that's why it was smart for the
play
to do the deal and take the deal and I
think it was that that uncertainty that
popped up last Thursday Friday and into
Saturday that pushed this over the top
by sixty total votes I think without the
craziness that really was sparked when
the NBA pulled the plug on its season
without that I think the CBA fails and
there would have been a lot of owners
happy about it Peter you had the quote
of the month in your column that every
time the stock market goes down a
thousand points there's another owner
that wants his vote back and I think a
lot of owners would have been happy to
see this deal go away forever
and then start it all from scratch on
the other side of this crisis you know
Mike the person who told me that was
very concerned because I obviously I
wanted to use that I wasn't gonna use
the name of that person but he thought
it was inflammatory incendiary and I
happened to talk to him this week and I
said see you were absolutely right
because how many owners right now right
now would vote for this deal 15 maybe I
think the majority well I shouldn't say
that but I think there's a good chance
they would not have gotten the votes if
that was up for a vote today
okay so free agency happened this week
as planned although it was somewhat
different than normal especially because
of the physicals constrained by the Cova
19 procedures the draft will happen
April 23 to 25 even if it is Roger
Goodell sitting by his fireplace in
slippers with a pipe and a newspaper
reading off the names one at a time and
will still have the highest ratings
we've ever seen for the draft
Peter the schedule usually comes out in
April should that continue or should
there be a different timetable for
announcing when and where the 256
regular season games will be played well
Mike that's a very very interesting
question because what has happened for
the last five years I have had access to
that room when they've made up the
schedule the first I think the first
four years I wrote about it and then
last year I did it as a
cast so I did it as sort of a live
podcast with Howard Katz and Mike North
and the people on the on the scheduling
team inside the NFL and it always has
seemed to me okay you're a wheat beef
they do this a week before the draft and
there is always this incredible intense
computer spitting out mando schedules
and and it's all for a rush because they
want to get this schedule out before the
draft and they don't want to get it out
on wednesday of draft week they want to
get it out the week before so people can
breathe and accept that and and sort of
you know figure out what this schedule
means and then the next week they you
know they have obviously the draft and I
think there are some people in the
league who've always said look we know
that people need to make plans teams
need to start scheduling we get that but
man it would be nice for the schedulers
if we knew what team to atong of Aloha
is playing for in 2020 in 2020 and and
some other people not only to give this
a little bit of time to breathe in a
year when right now if you're those guys
right now and you're sitting there and
you are less than a month before the
release date you're maybe 23 days before
the release date or 24 days something
like that
you have no idea who's playing
quarterback for the New England Patriots
you have no idea what's gonna happen to
Cam Newton you you have no idea for
instance what's gonna happen probably on
four or faut they got big decisions to
be made on four or five marquee teams
you know you're putting the the Chiefs
on six times in in in primetime you know
that but I do think that there is some
situation right now in some sentiment
inside the league where they might want
to wait until they have a little bit
more certainty especially with what with
everything else is going on and Mike
there's one other thing that a smart
person like you would realize when
considering this one of the things that
I kept thinking about when Tom Brady was
choosing his team it was very very it
was a big deal in some circles inside
the NFL honestly I think the NFL would
much rather have had Tom Brady choose an
AFC team okay because if you think about
it where are all the drawers right now
okay the drawers right now with the
exception of say the Chiefs and
traditional drawers kind of like the
Steelers okay you know there's not
really a draw in the AFC South you know
there's there's you know obviously the
Ravens and the Steelers you know are a
draw but if the Patriots play Andy
Dalton there's gonna be a lot of people
who are gonna look at the Patriots out
of curiosity but if they're 1 in 3 on
October 1st they don't want the Patriots
in primetime and and so you look at the
AFC look at the AFC where are the big
attractions so now you look at the NFC
and oh my god now they got Tom Brady and
all of a sudden the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
are gonna have to be a five-time
primetime team they're gonna have to be
they're not gonna be playing at one
o'clock on Sundays anymore very much so
you try to look at all these things and
does that mean for instance that they do
a lot more crossover games this year
than they normally do there's all these
things that if I'm just looking at it
Mike I say I will not be surprised if
the NFL says we're gonna release the the
schedule this year on on May 2nd and not
April 18th well I also think Peter
there's wisdom in creating more
an event from the scheduled release
instead of a week before the draft if
you bump it into May middle of May you
make it another tentpole right free
agency this week a great diversion and
distraction for people who needed it the
draft will be the same thing you push
the schedule into May for the reasons
you discussed and from a business
standpoint there's a way to build it up
there's a way to milk it there's a way
to maybe bleed it out over multiple days
where they announced the schedule maybe
one team at a time or something like
that to give the rest of us something we
can sink our teeth into and fully and
properly digest and fill that void on
the calendar and it's not just
selfishness by the NFL to try to own the
moment it's the idea that it gives
people something that will keep them
sane at a time when they're going to be
expected to stay inside so you could
make the schedule release I think a
three night event a Tuesday Wednesday
and Thursday night in the middle of May
just to give people something to look
forward to and something they'll stay
home and watch and they need these are
all look there they need somebody in the
NFL whose job is to do one thing and one
thing only identify all the ways the
world is going to potentially unfold
over the next six months and come up
with every possible strategy and
possibility for filling those voids and
handling those issues in a way that is
good for the league and that is good for
the people who rely on it I'll tell you
what you're one insane human being is
anybody I told you that by a three-day
schedule really hey I'm not saying it's
wrong I'm not saying it's wrong I'm
saying that's what we've come to because
you understand that anything any little
any little nugget about the NFL is going
to be a 40-minute show on ESPN I mean
right because it's and it's something
that makes any it makes people it gives
you something to look forward to and it
makes people willing to stay inside and
comply with what they need to do so they
really need to think about it I think
you're on to something there for a
variety of reasons they should bump it
into May who cares if if Ron Rivera
doesn't know when he's gonna face the
Cowboys is it early is it late how does
that really affect the draft anyway gee
I better go out and get more corners coz
I faced I faced the Cowboys week 1 I'd
forget about it move it forward and I
agree with you on that completely all
right we've talked about the draft the
Detroit Lions hold the third overall
pick there is an urgency in Detroit to
win now in order to save jobs Martha
Firestone Ford made it clear in December
she's sticking with the front office and
coaching staff but she expects more now
what are your thoughts on where the
Lions currently are where they need to
go and what they need to do with that
pick that they hold in the top five Mike
I I guess I understand why you end up
trading darius slay if you're if you're
the brain trust you know of of this team
and if you're Bob Quinn and Matt
Patricia I get it I really do but at
some point you've got to start signing
your big players to second contracts and
holding on and building a team okay
because theoretically and I forget it
might have been Todd McShea it might
have been Daniel Jeremiah I forget who
but right after the combine and they
said hey the it looks like the Lions
might lose Darius slay so they've got to
take a CUDA they got to sit here at
number three and take far and away the
best cornerback in this draft the kid
for Ohio State oco-2 Jeff Okuda so and I
thought to myself they've already got on
their team in their organization a
really good shutdown corner and somehow
someway he's gonna walk out the door and
you can't keep doing this when you have
the third pick in the draft you should
use it
to really improve your team not to be
like this not to and and again look I
guess Okuda is gonna be better than
darius slay even though i think there's
no question slays the top 10 12 corner
in the NFL but but so i guess i look at
it and i say the lions too
me are just sitting there treading water
and you know to lose one corner then go
get another one and I don't know what
they're gonna do with their pick none of
us do but to me I think that that
bothers me about the Detroit Lions right
now and the build of the Detroit Lions
yeah and look one of the realities
that's going on in Detroit now and we
saw it play out in the comments of
Darius slay made to Dave Burke head of
the Detroit Free Press on his way out
the door the culture change is still a
work in progress and I know that when
guys leave New England they leave Bill
Belichick they believe they're gonna do
things their own way what they don't
realize is his ways are baked into who
they are as coaches it's all they've
known it's all they've seen format
Patricia it was 1415 years of watching
Bill Belichick do what he does one of
the things Darius lay complains about is
that Patricia put up film of slay
getting abused by a receiver in a
practice session and Slayton like that
well Bill Belichick did that all the
time to Tom Brady and everyone else
prior regimes in Detroit apparently
didn't call out the star players who had
bad plays in practice that is an example
a tangible example of the clash of a
team that's been crap all due respect
for 60 years and a guy who comes in with
14 years of experience working for the
the gold standard the platinum standard
organization in the NFL and it's taking
time to make it mesh because the guys
who were there under a much more
lackadaisical regime are finding out
that they don't like it with Matt
Patricia they're doing things whether he
realizes it or not the patriot way and I
think with that third overall pick Peter
what they need to be sure they do is
find a guy who's going to be all-in with
the way they do things in New England
and ideally I'm a firm believer and when
you have multiple needs trade down and
get more lottery tickets and hope you
get more winners and try to find more
guys who will come in and convert that
culture to what it is that Matt Patricia
and Bob Quinn are trying to put in
Detroit Mike do you remember this is a
long time ago and you are still a
stately Mike Florio Esquire lawyer in
West Virginia at the time
but do you remember I think it was Labor
Day weekend 2003 where the New England
Patriots cut lawyer Milloy and they
wanted them to take a pay cut he said
absolutely no way even though you know
it had just been like a year previous
that they had won a Super Bowl then they
didn't make the playoffs the next year
and now they were entering 2003 so you
know Belichick had been there three
years he had won one Super Bowl
yeah lousy year the first year an OK
year the third year and they didn't and
they want a Super Bowl in a shock in
year two so he wasn't Bill Belichick yet
okay and lawyer Milloy just ripped the
Patriots for how they did business and
so on that first day of the season you
know after the Patriots lost 31 to
nothing
there was a newsroom - Malloy - Malloy
yeah yeah yeah and Tom Jackson of ESPN
had said on ESPN on that Sunday the New
England Patriots players hate their
coach okay and so I am getting into what
you are saying right now and we all know
so the Patriots won the Super Bowl that
year they won it the next year and they
would go on to win it three more times
you know in the last 15 years so so but
my point overall is I believe that even
though Belichick had won one Super Bowl
at the time he was trying to make one of
his defensive leaders take a pay cut
that he wasn't established to be able to
do these kind of things yet and have the
players just roll over
whereas now he kind of had they kind of
have to just roll over whatever he
decides even if it's Tom Brady in bill
we trust you know and so to me I kind of
look at this Mike is a little bit of the
same thing does Matt Patricia if he
shows film of of Darius slay getting
beat
to be doing that I think so and I but
but if he's gonna be doing that then his
team has to trust that this guy really
knows what he's doing
and Tom Brady in 2007 when Randy Moss
and Donte Stallworth walked into the
team for the first time and in the first
team meeting of the offseason in 2007
there's Randy Moss and Donte Stallworth
sitting together in the audience and
they've got a team meeting there's
whatever 6070 people in there and Bill
Belichick puts on tape of Tom Brady
making a crappy throw and throwing an
interception late in the previous season
and he said and Belichick says Brady
what the hell is this I could get Johnny
Foxborough to throw a better ball than
this and Randy Moss and Donte Stallworth
looked at each other and said Dorothy we
are not in Kansas anymore he's saying
that about the best quarterback in the
NFL and but he could say that it was the
same reason why Bill Parcells could say
that stuff about Phil Simms you know in
1987 and 88 because they had won a Super
Bowl and he had established himself in
his program as being so great so and
again I don't think that Matt Patricia
is doing a dumb thing by doing that but
it just goes to show you that the
players don't have that kind of respect
for Patricia maybe that the players in
New England half rubella check you know
it's funny the thing you mentioned the
same dynamic played out four years later
when Chad Johnson or Oh Joe Cinco
whichever surname he was going by at the
time was traded to the Patriots first
meeting tape from the divisional round
loss to the Jets the prior year after
the lockout right all the crap they got
to do to get a team ready with no
offseason program first team meeting
ripping Tom Brady for his performance
against the Jets in a game they lost to
Rex Ryan and company and Chad was like
holy crap if he's held to that standard
we're all held to that standard and it
works because they won that's the
challenge Peter if you're gonna be that
way you got to get the players to buy in
the
quickest way in the easiest way the most
effective way to get them buy-in is to
win so that's why the clock's ticking on
Matt Patricia he's not gonna be able to
force this culture change on the liens
and get them to buy into it unless they
win because if they're gonna be mediocre
it may as well be the way it was before
where it wasn't the coach is a butthole
and if the coach is gonna be a butthole
you better win or people are gonna check
out the media is gonna be all over you
and the next thing you know you're the
latest lions coach to get fired I'd
still take to a right at number three I
take to a may the best man win the job
and next year you go you get a one for
Matthew Stafford I mean well I know what
it kill you on the cap I get it but I
don't know I do not like it used to not
like it used to doesn't kill you like it
used to I mean the the Lions got yeah
Calvin Johnson and Dominic ensue and
Matthew Stafford all back in the days
before the rookie Wade scale so it's not
going to cost what it did and there may
be some wisdom in that to the extent
that you can develop him the way you
wanted to be and I think Toa will do
whatever I mean he survived with Nick
Saban for crying out loud
he'll do whatever Matt Patricia tells
him to do he is pre conditioned to deal
with a Bill Belichick type of a head
coach so I I agree with you give him a
year to sit behind Matthew Stafford
worry about Stafford next year and get
to a ready for 2021 all right speaking
of the Patriot weigh in Bill Belichick
Tom Brady finds his way out of New
England and the big question for the
Patriots is who will the quarterback be
they've seen an exodus of plenty of free
agents led by Brady Jared Stidham is on
the roster Andy Dalton is still
available Cam Newton may be cut and I
think as soon as today by the Carolina
Panthers because they're not gonna find
a trade partner for him what do you
think Bill Belichick does to fill that
quarterback position top of the depth
chart week one of the 2020 season who do
you think it's gonna be
well now that Duke Tobin has told Ian
Rapoport that we would work with Andy
Dalton on possibly finding him a new
place to play or whatever he did and I'm
paraphrasing that if I'm wrong it's
something like that now the Duke Tobin
has said that
what prevents every team in the NFL now
that there are not really a lot of teams
left Mike if you think about it what the
Chargers obviously the Patriots if
you're the Patriots right now if you're
the Patriots what prevents you from
saying cut them and then signing Andy
Dalton one year 7 million pruvit
contract has a and and they they agree
with him at the end of this we won't tag
you you know so in other words then you
don't have to pay Andy Dalton 17 you
could just pay him 7 or and and again
because my point is that Bellatrix gonna
sit on the sidelines and just wait and
see all these team all these
quarterbacks who you know need a place
to play they got a sign somewhere so
they may have to use 2020 as a audition
moment even though they've been quality
good NFL starters in the case of Cam
Newton and MVP why wouldn't the New
England Patriots just say on May 1st
we'll sign somebody we'll just see who's
out there because they're not all that
concern with who it is in my opinion is
and I've said this all along
I have zero insight information on this
zero but in my opinion all along Andy
Dalton has been a perfect Patriots guy
egoless dude hard worker will do
anything that they say never complains
he's got the Patriot ethos and again for
some reason hard for me to picture Cam
Newton that way you know the Cam Newton
I've seen in training camp with being
the the dancer and the Yeller and the
way and again that's fine
that's who he is and a lot of teams
that's wonderful
probably 25 teams that's wonderful just
can't imagine that happened in New
England but again I don't know Mike I
think they wait and they look at the
pool of quarterbacks whatever it is on
April 29th May 3rd whatever it is and
they pick one you know I agree with you
about
I'm fascinated by what Newton could do
with the Patriots because he's
two-and-oh all-time against the New
England Patriots and Bill Belichick has
had a hell of a time with mobile
quarterbacks and I'd love to see them
get one and that brings you back to
Taysom Hill we haven't heard much about
him this week other than there's a first
round tender that was applied to the
restricted free agent four point six
million dollars anyone can make him an
offer and usually that kind of stuff
happens after the first wave of free
agency but do you think the Patriots
will take a look at maybe trying to snag
Taysom Hill give up their first-round
pick pay Taysom Hill get him from the
Saints assuming they wouldn't match I
think they're gonna match whatever offer
is made but if I'm Bill Belichick I'm
intrigued by what Taysom Hill could be
if Josh McDaniels and Belichick craft an
offense to get the most out of them
there's no question about it I think
it's an intriguing thing to do it just
depends how much cash you have in year
one and how much cash you could put into
that contract the Saints are not in
great cap shape I think if somebody did
sign Taysom Hill that what the Saints
would have to do is redo about five
contracts because they're determined
that Taysom Hill gets a first shot in
2021 or whenever Tom Brady leaves I'm
Tom Brady Drew Brees leaves so I look at
this right now
I think Taysom Hill would be great for
them but I'm a little concerned
honestly that that the Patriots would
hand the reins to Taysom Hill and give
them the kind of contract that they
would have to give him without really
knowing this would be the ultimate leap
of faith by Bill Belichick does anybody
really know you know it's funny Mike I
looked at his stats at Brigham Young I
don't know one time this year I looked
them up they were not very good you know
and again you don't it's hard to tell
that obviously but Wow that would be a
gutsy call by the Patriots because they
have to put a lot of money into the
first year of the contract for the
Saints not to match yeah absolutely
absolutely and and
paetynn believes in him but whether that
translates to any other team that
remains to be seen it's a fascinating
possibility though because of the
mobility that he brings to the table and
the Patriots haven't had a guy like that
and they've had issues defending guys
like that throughout the course of the
last 20 years before we wrap and this
has been an extended discussion and I
appreciate it it's good that we've had
this platform to talk about a lot of
things happening the NFL Jameis Winston
clearly available now he told you in
August that he still harbors baseball
dreams and I've been mentioning that
thinking about that all week because
after making 45 million over the first
five years of his NFL career if no one
is gonna give him a chance to compete to
be a starter if he's gonna be a guy who
holds a clipboard does he at least
entertain the possibility of the Tim
Tebow route jump on the bus get on a
single-a team and try to play baseball
why not now if you're ever gonna do it
now's the time to do it and you're
walking away from what five six million
a year as a backup something you don't
want to do you want to play do you think
that this is the time for Jameis Winston
to indulge his desire to play baseball
Mike I think that before I would do that
if I were him and I think it's an
interesting question I have no idea what
his mental frame of mind right now is it
wouldn't shock me though because before
he I'll never forget this I talked to
him coming out of the combine in 2015
and he told me at the time that he would
love to be able in the offseason to
spend a couple of months being a closer
for somebody and you know we're pitching
somewhere he throws 95 he might be the
kind of guy with his sort of mental
frame of mind he's not an overly
emotional guy he might be the kind of
guy who you could say you know we'd let
him be a closer but I think of that and
then I think of where he is right now
and he probably really wants to show
people that the Bucks should have
believed in me this was a year one and
with Aryans and and I'm gonna be really
good but I think the biggest issue that
I have right now my biggest issue is I
would need somebody if I were Jameis
Winston to look at him and say you know
what I believe in you and I can make you
better and I know that everybody in
Pittsburgh has told me don't be an idiot
they're never gonna take Jameis Winston
Ben's the quarterback here for the next
couple of years if I was Mike Tomlin I
would think very seriously about trying
to have that conversation just to see if
there he can now why you know why can't
Mike Tomlin face time right now with
Jameis Winston have a heart-to-heart
talk with him
private nobody ever knows it happens
what why can't he do that just to see
where his head is at of course it'd be
better if he could do it face to face
but he can so why can't he face time
right now with Jameis Winston and just
talk to him about where he is does he
still want to be a great quarterback
would you sit for a year or two if I
gave you every chance to be next in
Pittsburgh and I don't disagree with
that conceptually but I'll tell you what
if I'm Jameis Winston I'm interested in
taking over Teddy Bridgewater's spot as
number two behind Drew Brees look at
what it did for Bridgewater Brees is
only there one more year maybe Brees
gets injured at some point is not if not
if Taysom Hill stays though I'm oh I
don't it yeah but but they need they
need a veteran who can run the standard
offense because Hills gonna need his own
offense they need somebody who's ready
to play and I think it would be and who
knows maybe Ben Roethlisberger suffers
another season-ending injury in week two
like last year I just think Drew Brees
is gonna be more welcoming to Jameis
then Ben Roethlisberger would be I think
Ben's gonna be a little more territorial
about this especially as he tries to
re-establish himself after last season I
think that is the the potential pressure
point there I don't think Ben wants
someone that would threaten him
implicitly I think Brees is fine with it
Brees is getting his money he's there
one more year and that's that and
if he gets to play in a couple of games
maybe kind of cleanses the palate and
get somebody to say all right you know
what with the right coach he's not gonna
have a bunch of interceptions he's not
gonna average almost two per game he can
be taught he can learn I think to me
that's his best opportunity if he wants
to lay the foundation to be a starter
again in the future yeah I guess so Mike
but I'm not sure that Ben Roethlisberger
should have that that power inside the
Steelers
he shouldn't how can you be sure that
Ben Roethlisberger of--this burgers
playing 15 games this year if I gave you
an over-under right now if Vegas didn't
over-under starts by Ben Roethlisberger
this year what would it be eight and a
half twelve right yeah so what I know
you know I think his body could be it
could be it could go ahead of court why
should Ben Roethlisberger be all pissy
if they bring in Jameis Winston really
think about it yeah I don't say B or if
they bring in Andy Dalton if they bring
in a guy who's been an established
starter we can't rely on you Ben we
can't we want you to be our quarterback
if you're healthy for the next three
years wonderful then we have misjudged
and overpaid a backup guy and a
potential heir but hey if we have to do
that great you know and I don't look I I
think you're right and he had mike vick
there as a backup at one point and my
god if he can survive mike vick being a
backup in pittsburgh he can survive
Jameis Winston or Andy Dalton I just
think that from the standpoint of the
overall likelihood of Jameis Winston
parlaying this year into starting again
next year
I'd be more inclined to go with Sean
Payton and fill that spot the Teddy
Bridgewater had for the last couple of
years because it worked
21 million per year for Bridgewater
after playing six games since the end of
the 2015 season all right Peter we have
gone for a long time I appreciate it
it's not gonna be that is nothing to be
open if taste some Hills on the roster
anyway yeah they still need a
and back up though they still need a
veteran backup because they you can't
have two different offenses you got to
have somebody who can run the drew brees
offense we'll see how it plays out all
right excellent stuff everybody stay
safe Peter you stay safe take care of
your spouse take care of Chuck and know
when to pull the pin and get the hell
out of there and hopefully hopefully
that won't come anytime soon and again
we wish everybody the best thanks for
joining us all week long we're back on
NBCSN on Monday Sky Sports on Monday Pro
Football Talk calm all weekend long and
Peter Kings
free agency football morning in America
coming up Monday morning check that out
everybody have a great weekend we'll see
you on Monday
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports